where do conservatives lose you so if
for them to get somebody to like to
where do they lose you what what would
they need to do to get you
um the number one thing
is conservatives need to understand that
the environmental crisis is not
synonymous with climate change that we
have a clear environmental crisis what
we are doing to the planet cannot be
undone ever and so we must figure out
how to stop doing it and that's true
irrespective of the reality or fiction
involved in climate change and I'm
pretty convinced there is both so that's
one what else where else do they lose
you
um the idea that we
should return to a prior state with
respect to uh
how we deal with each other socially
right so there's a recognition that
something has gone very wrong for
example in the relationship between the
Sexes that's simply true it's gone very
wrong but we can't go back there's
nowhere to go back to right things began
to change radically at the I mean we
can't go back to be specific so when
you're saying they want to go back to
what do they want to go back to a
traditional relationship between men and
women and there are aspects of a
traditional relationship that I think
ought to be resurrected but there's we
can't go back because
what changed our circumstances was the
introduction of reliable birth control
that was the thing that changed and
everything else are it's sort of a
cascading set of
dysfunctions that have Arisen Downstream
of that because what it did is it
removed the central logic of the system
and I'm not claiming that the central
logic of the system was fair I don't
think it was but the central logic of
the system was reliable and had been
reliable literally for
well there's an argument to be made for
hundreds of millions of years right the
reality of male and female and the
relationship between those two phenomena
had had some consistency for hundreds of
millions of years it had certainly been
consistent for human history and
pre-history and then suddenly the
introduction of birth control Alters
that relationship in a fundamental way
and there was not the I mean there was a
certain amount of consternation over
what would happen but it wasn't
um I don't think it properly understood
that it was going to
rob the system of the incentive that had
driven civilization forward
so let's stay there okay so one uh uh
conservatives uh don't have climate
change as their priority is what you're
saying not climate change this is the
problem environmental sustainability
let's say okay when when conservatives
hear somebody say environment or
environmental crisis their mind
transmutes that into global warming
because this has become the the flagship
issue and the problem is conservatives I
believe are correct that they detect
nonsense around that issue that they are
being told something that is not a
complete story that where they're told
we must follow the science on climate
change we have an emergency and then the
science amounts to models that they
cannot evaluate they have the sense that
something is being smuggled in and I
don't think they're wrong about that
however that's not the same thing as
saying climate change isn't real and
important and more to the point
the issue of environmental
sustainability is a real issue
irrespective even if you found out that
climate change was a complete fiction
right it doesn't change the fact that we
are in an environmental crisis that
urgently needs our attention so those
are two different things though right
because what you're saying is one is I
don't know if conservatives are saying
that climate change is fake and it's 100
fabricated et cetera Etc when they're
saying that money is being used let's
not you know fool ourselves there's a
lot of gaslighting going on behind
closed doors I mean did you see the clip
these guys had Rebel news media did you
see them interviewing uh Greta Thon work
did you see that fake op-ed she did with
the police in Germany and that video and
then this uh have you seen this one or
nowhere she's she you haven't seen this
I'm aware that it exists I'm trying not
to process it too much because I don't
even know what it is so so but the point
is like she was doing in a picture like
she got arrested and then she tweeted
saying I got arrested by the German
police and then these guys at Rebel news
followed her if you can just click on it
I've gotten permission from them they
responded back to me I was filming your
arrest watch this
it's in Germany because it looked like
you did that in several takes didn't you
watch this you were posing with the
police
he's answering for you he's he's
answering for you he said you had an
agency what what I wish I had one it
would be much simpler than well who was
filming you then I don't know media you
don't know who is filming you in Germany
he said he knows he says it was an
agency
agency you idiots
do you normally have reporters defending
you
on police and rwa fossil fuel company
which stage
how many how many times did you were you
arrested because you posed for several
times didn't you
sure
so so for example a that's not a
conservative that says why are you
making propaganda videos using a young
girl who's no longer young she's 19 or
20 years old right now I'm sorry I don't
like to be gaslighted that's not a
conservative thing I relate more to
libertarian philosophy but if I have to
choose between you two on who I vote for
I'm going to go on one side I think the
position from conservatives haven't
debated a lot haven't had a lot of these
guys on on that specific topic is look
we don't know
you know where the left says no we know
this is the number one crisis we're
dealing with and the conservatives are
saying we don't know for a fact you know
the Earth's been around for a long time
how do you know for a fact how do I know
for a fact so let's keep that as a
discussion versus I know for a fact
right and then the second part you
talked about
uh on going back to uh you know uh
family well family nucleus you know
going back to traditional Family Values
birth control you know which 1950 kind
of changed the game when that came out
well sometimes uh uh you know I see that
as a test we do like I would assume as a
scientist I'm not a scientist but in we
run a company and we'll say Let's test
this comp plan
to see if it works and then all of a
sudden you're like oh this comp plan
produces terrible results guys let's go
back to the old comp plan there is
nothing wrong with that you know when
you introduce a new compensation
structure or a new model or a new
segment or a new show and you're like
dude this is a terrible show we just
launched we did 10 of them already they
don't like it let's just cut it we're
not going to continue funding this show
what's wrong with saying this one area
we were willing to be gentle with and
open-minded to guess what it's not
producing the right results we got to go
back to the principles that produce
results so are we talking about climate
change or [__] not climate change
we're talking about uh family Dynamics
yes oh nothing's wrong with it except
that it's never going to happen
what do you mean by that what I mean is
prior to Reliable birth control
there was a structure that was imposed
on us by Nature
and again I'm not defending it as fair
but what it was was coherent
and that structure came from the fact
that human babies are incredibly
expensive to raise and I don't mean that
financially I mean the investment that
goes into a human baby is like no other
creature
what that means is that it requires more
than one person to raise one
which then means that a woman would be
crazy if she had a choice to choose to
produce an offspring that she would have
to raise alone if she had the option to
raise it with a partner okay so it is
that extreme cost which Falls initially
entirely on women that they can then
redistribute with a partner
that cost drives the system
on the flip side of that
you have the fact that
sex for men is one of the
maybe it is the most potent motivator in
the universe there is nothing that tops
it and so in a world where women guard
their reproductive capacity carefully
because they do not want to accidentally
produce a child for which they will be
fully responsible for raising it
men have to live up to whatever standard
women set in order to be worthy of a
sexual relationship which is the
ultimate goal of the evolutionary
exercise
that was a coherent world not fair but
coherent
you introduce birth control in which sex
and reproduction are now technologically
separated from each other and that logic
no longer works now it took decades for
it to fully break down but we are at the
point where this logic has now given way
and young people do not inherently see
the logic of finding a partner they
don't inherently see the logic of
producing Offspring and while not having
a partner and not producing offspring
are valid choices I would defend
people's right to make those choices the
degree to which people have lost sight
of why they might want to do those
things should be alarming to us so is
your position pro-choice pro-life is is
that what you're saying as your second
one to make it a little bit more
specific for the audience I'm not really
advocating for a solution here we could
talk about what Solutions might be no no
a question I'm asking is like when I
said what what do conservatives need to
do to get your vote and you said number
one is sustainability the fact that they
don't even want to give the you know
where I said to you I think the left is
more certain that there's climate change
to write is just saying let's be
skeptical and let's be open the fact
that maybe there isn't maybe this is a
natural cycle the second one you said
how you know 1950 to birth control so is
is your second one saying that the right
is too convinced that it has to be
pro-life where it's pro-choice you know
this is a funny issue I have known for
since I started thinking about it
decades ago that there was vastly more
agreement on the issue of choice than we
acknowledge that our our discussion has
become extremely polarized but most
people fall out in a camp that is that
believes there is some right
to terminate a pregnancy very early
while we are talking about something
that is uh
has certainly the potential to become a
human but does not have the
characteristics of a a human yet and
people grow increasingly uncomfortable
the closer we get to the moment of birth
that's where almost all of us are now
there's a group of people
who has a religious perspective that I I
respect which says you're interfering in
a Divine process something has decided
to produce a child and you are deciding
to override it and that is the reason
that a certain brand of religious
conservative does not see any room for
uh for terminating a pregnancy but that
is a small fraction of the population
most of us believe there is some right
to that technology and that that right
grows less and less compelling the
closer we get to the moment of birth
okay so you know by and large I don't
I don't need
religious conservatives to give up their
commitment to their understanding of how
the universe works and frankly I think
the bias that this is a sobering
decision is the right one for sure but
you know how should Society be governed
well it should be governed approximately
where we all fall out we're not overly
comfortable with this process but but we
believe that it has to exist in some
form for lots of reasons I mean
rape and incest being
an obvious an obvious case where for
most of us the idea that a rapist can
inflict a pregnancy on a woman and that
she has no right to end it is
preposterous
yeah that that uh that by the way that's
also where
uh conservatives are conflicted meaning
amongst each other so I don't know if
that makes sense like some of them are
from the standpoint of no even if it is
rape even if it is this even if it is
that you know you still got a dude which
you know that's
considered extremists if a person wants
to take that position and some say no
that's not the part I'm talking about
the part I'm talking about which by the
way I saw a joke the other day by a guy
I'm going to give this guy a shout out
Jeffrey asmus which I thought was was
very funny have you seen this one where
he gets up and he says I never
understood why conservatives or
Republicans are approach pro-life
he says Republicans should stay
pro-choice
he says you know why he says wait for it
it's going to take you five seconds to
get this he says why he says because
most kids that get aborted are liberals
did you get it yeah so you're sitting
there kind of thinking about it where
what a heavy joke right there because if
you think about who and what ethnicity
pro-choice Hurts the Most it's
you know most of the abortions in
America if you you can look at the data
you know the data already yourself
but okay so let's let's let's go past
this one let's go wait wait I think
there's one point that needs to be on
the table because I do know that
conservatives are conflicted amongst
themselves about this question and there
is a an argument that absolutely belongs
on the table in that argument what's
there in that context
the argument is they're actually has to
be a right for a woman who has been
raped to terminate that pregnancy and I
would hope that it happens as early as
possible for many reasons
the reason is an evolutionary one
if you create a scenario in which a
woman is forced to carry the product of
rape to the point of giving birth and
raising this child you are opening up a
strategy for rapists to reproduce and
the problem is that that's extreme
breadth you're taking a very extreme
position in what way I mean you so
here's the part that that uh both the
left and the right does that they uh
take an argument that happens less than
one percent of the time and they use
that as the basis for the argument on
why a hundred percent of the other
side's position isn't right but I'm not
saying that but that's a very small
minute uh position you know in in case
that we're talking about why
tell us why because rape is not
something that is you know as if if we
take a hundred of the pregnancies that
happen yeah and we say well let's really
get some data on what caused these
pregnancies one night stands boyfriend
girlfriend didn't you know uh use a
condom uh you were on the dates you were
off you forgot to take the pill how
often do people forget to take the pill
there's a lot of kids that are born
because somebody forgot the Wednesday
pill or the Friday pill you know you got
somebody that just wants to have the
kids because the tax code benefits
somebody having kids and getting free
money from the government another one
could be let me lock up a guy who's got
money man if I have his baby he has to
pay me you know child support there's a
the tax code benefits
women getting pregnant
as a to a certain sect that do take
advantage of that system but to say rape
rape would be at the bottom of a very
low low very small fraction let's keep
it that way that's my point is that if
you if you if you open the door to a
strategy in which a rapist who can
trigger a pregnancy can have we can
basically force a woman to give birth to
that child and in most cases to raise it
what you are doing is you are inviting a
future in which rape is more common
right because it becomes a viable
evolutionary I don't I don't I don't
know if I uh
I don't know if I agree with that
because there's there's two things to it
the forget about the viable strategy
one of the strategies of raping is
you're going to jail yeah so so the the
crime the punishment you know we can
make that more severe where in certain
cities in America it's not treated that
way certain cities in America it's kind
of like wow you know he's okay let's
give him a second chance third chance
four chance there's a lot of cities in
America that have rapists walking around
because they're forgiving rapists that's
not the fact that we're saying let's
keep the baby if you're raped by a man
that's because of laws are forcing some
people to say I can get away with murder
and rape well I would certainly support
stronger laws in cases where you
actually prove a you know stranger rape
is the case that we're talking about
here then my sense is somebody who would
engage in that doesn't you know doesn't
really deserve a second chance if you're
capable of that what are the chances
that when you get out of prison you're
gonna you know do it again be a uh yeah
the chances you're going to do it again
are high but the fraction of rapes that
are actually successfully prosecuted is
low and so both things are true yes by
driving the penalty up for somebody who
gets caught you can reduce the viability
of the strategy but not sufficiently and
so all I'm saying as an evolutionist I
know that I know it's a rough argument
but the argument is you don't want this
strategy to be a winner I don't think I
don't think conservatives are going to
be sitting there supporting that but the
question then becomes too so so flip it
so you got two sides here as a person
who is you and your wife
Evergreen you're the top Prof your
wife's the top Professor you're right
behind her top Professor so essentially
you guys are the top two professor in
school 15 years you got a 16 year old
you got an 18 year old I think it's fair
to say your kids are not going to go to
Evergreen is that a pretty a good
assessment right there no they won't be
all right sir
but but here's a part as a parent now
it's different when you're a 29 year old
Progressive versus a 44 year I don't
know your age but I'm assuming we're the
same age 44 year old Progressive yeah
I'm 53 but well great you you look good
so okay so a 53 year old Progressive you
know your your Optics have changed
you're looking at it from your kids
you're seeing how you were treated
you're seeing how maybe you were even on
their side and arguing on their uh side
now you're sitting there saying listen
you know certain things in life of
values are no longer the same what I
used to vote for that was number one
that was number 13 what I voted for was
number two and I was 28 but what I
thought it was number 17 is now number
two what's what is what are your top uh
three four five reasons on to say I
think this party has what I support and
I think this party does what are the top
four five things you vote for
well I should tell you neither of these
parties are viable they're both so
deeply corrupt that uh I don't see
um I don't see either of them being
resurrected in some form and you know
again this is this is exactly why I say
reluctant radical
we are now at a place that we have to
radically alter this system in order for
there to be a system at all 200 years
from now
and I care very deeply about this I do
have two kids as you point out and I'm
very concerned about what world they are
emerging into and what will they will
produce children in
um so I wish I wish I could say look
here's what you need to do to fix the
Republican Party here's what you would
have to do to get the Democrats back on
track this is too far gone right this is
these are both influence peddling
rackets and we suffer from it daily I
mean and I know it's a very dangerous
topic
but I don't think we're ever going to
get a better peek at how the system
really works than looking at the
pandemic that we have just experienced
right that's the quality of governance
that we've got it's not good enough to
manage a species playing with tools as
powerful as the ones that we have it's
just not going to work so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]